welcome back to las vegas now as the
wedding capital of the world there's no
better place for a three-day expo for
bridal and formal attire let's check in
with rocky who is live at day one of the
las vegas bridal market hi rocky are you
finding me some sequins
hey
oh my gosh am i this place is full of
sequins formal dresses wedding dresses
you seriously would be at disneyland
jillian and for you guys watching this
isn't for actual buyers so if you're
looking to get a wedding dress this is
not for you but it's for the people that
you would buy your wedding dress from is
that right that's exactly right this is
for boutique owners this is where the
buyers come and they pick out the next
trends they're putting the dresses in
the boutiques for you to buy so this is
a very important event for those buyers
so when you're looking at wedding dress
trends you guys actually know what's
coming up for the seasons oh absolutely
the designers create the trends and then
when we show the new collections the
buyers for the boutiques see those
trends and that's who brings them to the
buyers in the stores i love it okay so
because you are the expert
tell us what are some of the trends that
you're seeing right now out there in the
wedding world well a big trend right now
you'll see a lot of color you'll see a
lot of color in dresses and then you'll
also see transitional dresses those
second looks something that you can take
the skirt off and it's a fitted dress
underneath or we have been seeing a huge
trend with short dresses as well i love
that okay that brings me to brittany
brittany i'm coming over to you girl
hold on i'm gonna come around your
beautiful models so let's talk let's
break down this look maybe one one of
the looks or break down both if you can
sure absolutely so this is a danny girl
gown and a huge thing right now is
accessorizing so this for example is
just a little detachable bow train which
a girl can do for her ceremony and then
take it off for the reception
yes and this one for example it just
i'll show you here it just unbuttons
right up here
snaps off
and then boom she's got a hole
you know for my future reception i might
have to go with something like that
right a short dress yes the short gowns
another way to transition we actually
have seen a ton of brides are doing two
different looks right now so this is
just a beautiful lace gown with sparkle
it's completely customizable so the girl
can just have a second look on her
wedding night i love you guys look
beautiful
all that representation too it's
beautiful okay so let's talk now because
melange de blanc you guys have a website
that people can go to to find out you
know what's going on here since the
actual buyers or the excuse me the
future brides can't come here to get
their dress yes exactly so melange de
blanc we represent multiple designers
and you can go to the melange debunk
website
and it will show you all of the
designers that we're showcasing and then
you can go to the designer's website to
see what stores in your area have those
gowns so you can find out a little bit
behind the scenes i love it okay hunter
join us join us join us so ladies would
you say there is a favorite local las
vegas boutique that you guys know and
love
for us it's so hard to choose a favorite
because there's so many good boutiques
and you can definitely find the
boutiques in your area that carry the
designers that you love on certain
designers websites so i don't know if i
can pick a favorite it's a little too
hard for us
so many good boutiques
personally i love made in white i do
love made in white they have beautiful
dresses and they work with you guys too
right
and for everybody out there just a
little advice on how to shop for your
wedding dress
coming with an open mind definitely do
your research instagram is such a tool
to use and also just know your budgets
in your style like be yourself that's
also what we're seeing a lot in this
year coming up is people really being
true to who they are and being bold with
their fashion
being bold with your fashion being bold
brides i love it thank you everybody you
guys this is the las vegas bridal market
the first annual so cheers to many more
years of helping ladies feel good on
their wedding day we'll be right back in
las vegas